[Music]
one thing I find really helpful when I'm
watching TV is that little info button
on the cable remote you know that button
I'm talking about you press it and it
brings up that screen that tells you
what you need to know about the show
you're watching yeah it's really helpful
absolutely why thought would take a look
at some info button results in a piece
called what am i watching everything
haven't checked in a while let's check
out 60 minutes I think 60 minutes is on
and ok let's check out the info button
see what they describe it serious and
thought-provoking look at issues
affecting our society as presented by
reanimated skeletons seems harsh let's
check out C Mon first let's check out
Dexter there's Dexter let's check out
what it says there the show that reveals
a sad truth the only worthwhile person
in Florida is a serial killer
Celebrity Apprentice Sears Celebrity
Apprentice let's see what the info
button says watch mini-me and the
replacement basis for Night Ranger fight
over who sold more lemonade
Sesame Street I'm gonna check out so
there's Sesame Street this should be
nice let's check out the info button on
that black magic enables puppets to
coexist with humans in an unnatural
urban dystopia
here's diners drive-ins and dives let's
check it out
one embarrassing clowns quest for the
ultimate case of diarrhea
[Applause]
[Music]
check out duck dynasty Oh duck dynasty
people love the show it's who the info
button says former members of ZZ Top do
something Chuck Dateline NBC see what
they say here about Dateline NBC every
week a respected small-town doctor
murders someone he loves
Wow that's more true than funny yeah
yeah Seinfeld let's check out the info
button you've seen this one Fashion
Police with Joan Rivers let's check it
out
half-melted talking candle honey
Who am I to judge let's check out the
next one CSI Miami there's CSI Miami
let's see what it says David Caruso acts
like a douche around corpses
and finally Conan hey there's Conan
unscripted reality show about a
man-child and his trusty friend of their
manchild
some of the others were harsh but that's
right that's just truth or